Who in the world is Admiral Greenbull?
How do his seemingly limitless powers work?
And will he turn out to be an enemy or ally
to Luffy's and the straw hats' cause?
We have been waiting for the reveal of this
man ever since Dressroa, where Doflamingo
revealed that the Marines had drafted not
one, but two power houses for the vacant admiral
positions left by Aojiki and Akainu.
And now, after many years of starving to see
what this man's powers look like, with Oda-sensei
feeding us nothing but a silhouette or two
here and there, we finally have seen what
the third marine admiral next to Kizaru and
Fujitora looks like and is capable of.
And my god is he capable.
Now I can't be the only one who'd love to
be as strong and fight like Greenbull.
And while I sadly don't have his devil fruit
for you to eat, I have today's sponsor to
help you out with this.
DNF Duel.
DNF Duel, is a new and exciting duelling fighting
game, that has just now released on PS4, PS5,
and PC - and it's packed with a lot of great
character design, lore, and more!
This game reworks 17 years of iconic Dungeon
and Fighter history into a whole new experience.
Even though I don't play a ton of fighting
games, it was super easy to pick up and get
obsessed with.
I really love the art style and the controls
feel incredibly intuitive.
So if you also feel the urge to fight,
DNF Duel is now available on PS4, PS5, and
PC ,on Steam - check it out now using the
link in my description below.
Greenbull, or Aramaki, as he's actually called,
is a tall, muscular man with shoulder long
black hair, a pair of badass black shades
and smoking a cigarette, which funnily enough
goes against his otherwise 'green' image.
He's refusing to wear a shirt under his admiral
coat, rightfully so, I wouldn't wear a shirt
either with that upper body, and he carries
an incredibly sleek looking Katana without
any sheath, but simply jammed into his belt.
He has a massive kanji tattoo on his chest,
in order: Death, River, Heart and Middle.
The last two kanji together read shinchuu,
which means double suicide committed by lovers.
But it can also mean one's true feelings or
true motives.
So I guess the tatoo reads something like
'lover's suicide on the river of death', while
it might also hint at Aramaki having hidden
motives compared to what he openly says.
I want you to remember that, because it will
be important in a second, when we talk about
Greenbull's true intentions.
He also wears tight pants with a sakura motive
on them, going well with his plant powers.
Now you will have noticed that Aramaki in
general has an incredibly Japanese vibe around
him.
Just like the actor Harada Yoshio who was
famous for his Ronin and Gangster roles, that
he is inspired by, I think Greenbull has pretty
strong Yakuza vibes.
The straight blade, no shirt under a jacket,
the sun glasses and the cigarette.
This is meant to be a classic Japanese gangster.
And it once again brings up a really interesting
and honestly important question that people
have been asking for quite a while now:
Is Aramaki from Wano?
Because while, the world of One PIece has
a lot of Japanese influence simply because
it's written by a Japanese author predominantly
for a Japanese audience, there is one place
in particular that is fully entered around
Edo Japan and Japanese culture, that even
has the Yakuza as an institution.
And that place is Wano.
This was also speculated for Fujitora, or
Issho, who also has an incredibly strong samurai
theme.
And as we know both of them not only got drafted
together, but they also seem to get along
really well and talk like old friends.
And what other place in One PIece could you
possible find such randomly powerful people
to draft into an admiral position than Wano,
the one country the government has never dared
to attack because of its powerful warriors
and that even Akainu doesn't want to send
troops to.
Remember, the admirals are the most powerful
force the marines have at their disposal.
The top tier fighters they have to face people
like Whitebeard or Shanks.
The original 3 admirals were shaped into these
monsters over decades within the marines.
So drafting someone form the outside into
this highest of positions, really speaks for
their power.
Oda has actually more or less confirmed in
an SBS that Fujitora and Greenbull share similarities
and might have ulterior motives that go against
the world government.
Both Issho and Aramaki have been ignoring
direct orders form Akainu multiple times and
Fujitora even abolished the Warlord system
that was one of governments most prized balancing
powers in the world.
One very intriguing possibility is that Fujitora
or Ryokugyo or maybe both are former Daimyo
or Yakuza bosses, that had left Wano before
or when Kaido took over the country.
Some clues that people like my good friend
Mr Morj have found, actually suggested that
Greenbull might have been Shimotsuki Ushimaru,
a man who has an actual bull on his coat as
his symbol and has the word ushi, which means
bull, in his name.
By the way in the anime, the bull on the Ushimaru's
coat is literally green.
The same Shimotsuki Ushimaru, that has now
been heavily suggested to be either Zoro's
father or at least some sort of relative.
One awesome example more brings up, is how
both Zoro and Ryokugyo are introduced as fasting,
with both luffy and Zoro commenting on it.
Ryukugyo says that he would only break his
fast for a pretty girl.
And Zoro literally breaks his fast to eat
the little girls Onigiri, that Helmeppo has
made fun of and stomped on.
Now.
After knowing what Ryokugyo and Ushimaru looks
like, your first reaction might be the same
as mine: These two look nothing alike.
At least that was genuinely my first impression.
But then I took these two images of the two
and put them into photoshop.
And you know what.
IT works.
Like, do you see what I'm seeing?
The eyebrows and eyes match up pretty much
perfectly.
The nose is exactly the same.
The teeth are exactly the same.
His mouth not only has the same expression,
but even the cigarette and the grass straw
are in the exact same position.
The only real difference is the hairstyle,
that let's be real could be really easily
changed.
And don't forget that 20 years have passed
between that scene in the cave with Yamato
and today.
So, if I had to bet any money on who Admiral
Greenbull is, I would absolutely go with Shimotsuki
Ushimaru, who also is Zoro's father.
And I think this would explain everything
we have seen from Greenbull so far absolutely
perfectly.
Of course he would come right back to wano
after Kaido's defeat.
He and the other daimyo's tried fighting back
against Kaido and his armies but were defeated.
He probably joined up with the marines in
the first place due to his hatred for pirates
and what they did to his country, similar
to how Fujitora couldn't stand Doflamingo's
unjust rule over dressrosa.
They might have joined the marines to finally
defeat pirates like Kaido in the first place.
I actually think it's quite possible that
both Greenbull and Fujitora only got their
respective devil fruits when they joined up
with the marines and were drafted as admirals.
Greenbull ignoring Akainu's orders and coming
to Wano to see what's going on would be only
logical, if it's actually his home country.
Not only would he want to make sure that the
beast pirates are taken care of for good,
which is literally the very first thing he
does when arriving, but he would also want
to make sure that no other pirate takes Kaido's
place, which is why he's planning to take
Luffy's head.
He would want to see a free wano, not simply
one tyrant replaced by the next.
Because as far as Aramaki knows, Luffy is
a wanted dangerous criminal.
He hasn't met Luffy yet.
Luffy, who now has a ridiculous bounty of
3 Billion berries.
Very much unlike we here on this channel with
a bounty of 61 Million, 100 berries for each
subscriber.
So rather than becoming a YOnko, our big goal
is fighting hard to overtake the slimiest
man in all of One PIece, who for some reason
has a bounty of 99 million.
Please go help me win this fierce race to
100M by hitting subscribe and getting freshly
baked One Piece content every single week.
now, My biggest argument for Greenbull loving
Wano and hating the Beast pirates for what
they did however is this panel from chapter
1053.
Where we see Udon Prison from afar.
Compare this to this panel here where we first
get introduced to the prison as it is surrounded
by a deadly wasteland.
Greenbull is literally reviving Wano and returning
all it's lushness and nature.
He uses all of the beast pirates energy to
rejuvenate Wano.
ANd he's doing that to all of the country
as he's making his way form Udon to the flower
capital.
This isn't just a random side effect of his
powers.
Because otherwise, we would have seen flowers
and plants spring up all around him on Marijois
as well.
No, this is Greenbull actively using all the
energy he has absorbed to do this.
And so the question is, what will happen,
once Greenbull actually reaches the capital?
Because I personally think, that he is quite
serious about taking Luffy's head.
Aramaki seems to be no fan of the world government,
just like Fujitora, but that is also true
for Akainu as we know.
There is a lot of movement inside the Marines
right now to reform and become independent
form the world government.
Including people like Garp, Koby, X Drake,
but also the fleet admiral himself.
And so I think that Greenbull can be against
the world government, but still pro Akainu,
supporting his style of leadership and trying
to get his approval.
This actually caught my interest as well.
As you might know, the admirals follow a very
interesting color scheme.
You have the 3 primary colors, red, yellow
and blue, that you can use to mix any other
color with.
Mixing Red and Blue for instance gives us
Fujitora's purple.
And I think Fujitora's justice, is indeed
located somewhere between Akainu's red and
Aokiji's blue.
Incredibly strict and merciless like Akainu,
but open to exceptions and reason, like in
Luffy's case, similar to Aokiji.
In that sense, Greenbull would be a mix between
Aokiji and Kizaru.
Incredibly powerful and destructive when unleashed,
but also pretty laid back and curious, like
Kizaru was on Sabaody.
This goes very well Greenbulls relaxed nature
that we saw on Marijois.
Should Greenbull actually turn out to be Ushimari
however, in other words Zoro's father, that
would instantly solve my one big issue with
the ending to wano so far: Zoro's unresolved
connection to the country.
So Greenbull's solo arrival at the flower
capital might very well be exactly that, Zoro
meeting his father and either learning about
his heritage or, he might already be aware
about it and simply recognise his father.
Depending on how young he was when he got
separated form his parents.
I think an admiral crashing the party in the
capital, like Aokiji did during water 7, would
be epic enough by itself, but this sort of
connection would make it even better than
it already is by itself.
But let's also talk about Aramaki's powers
by themselves for a bit.
Because just how wood is incredibly overpowered
in the world of Naruto, they seem to be incredibly
overpowered here as well.
Not only can Greenbull build any structure
with his powers, he is literally able to take
life energy and redistribute it by growing
plants of any type.
This seems ridiculously powerful even by admiral
standards.
It also really makes me wonder what type of
devil fruit this is.
My first reaction was to categorise this as
a paramecia or special paramecia fruit, being
able to generate plants with his body.
But at the same time, the fact, that he can
drink Sake though the roots and steal power
from others for himself almost makes it seem,
like his body might made from plants, as in
he might be a plant logia fruit user.
I'm just super curious to find out what his
actual devil fruit is called and categorised
at.
And of course find out more about his true
intentions and what he's like as a person.
Since we just found out that Momo's grandfather,
Kozuki Sukiyaki is alive as well, if Greenbull
is a former Daimyo, he would surely recognise
him as well.
No matter what way you look at it, Greenbulls
introduction, together with the reveal of
the new Yonko has changed the power dynamics
of the one piece world fundamentally.
And if you wnat to understand what that means
for the future of the one piece world, you
really shouldnt miss this video right here.